Madame Massé, merci de
nous accorder un peu de temps
en cette fin de campagne.
- Ça me fait vraiment plaisir
d'être avec vous.
- Madame Massé, vos idées sont,
disons, rafraîchissantes.
En tout cas, elles plaisent
visiblement à de plus en plus
d'électeurs. Mais il y a quand
même une question qui demeure
dans la tête de bien des gens.
Est-ce que c'est réaliste, là?
Je vais prendre juste un
exemple. Et les gens des régions
vont m'excuser, mais je vais
prendre le transport collectif
à Montréal, par exemple.
Vous dites : «On va injecter
10 milliards dans le premier
mandat, 38 stations de métro.»
On rêve, là, vraiment.
Vous nous faites rêver.
Mais est-ce que c'est faisable
quand on sait que ça a pris...
Depuis 10 ans, on n'en
a pas eu une à Montréal,
une station de métro.
MANON MASSÉ, co-porte-parole
Québec solidaire
- Ouais. Bien, en fait, c'est
réaliste quand il y a la volonté
politique derrière. Vous savez,
pour nous, à Québec solidaire,
l'urgence climatique nécessite
qu'on mette tous les moyens
nécessaires pour qu'on fasse
notre part ici au Québec.
Et le transport des individus,
c'est de loin ce qui est le plus
producteur de gaz à effet
de serre. Alors, nous, on dit :
On prend le problème à
bras-le-corps. On donne
le virage nécessaire. Et les
38 stations, vous comprenez
bien, seront pas construites en
quatre ans, mais les chantiers
vont être enclenchés. Et oui,
le projet du Grand Montréal
Express, bien, il va naître
sous un Québec solidaire.
- Mais vous voulez financer
vos promesses notamment en
taxant les grandes entreprises.
- Oui.
- Est-ce que vous avez mesuré
l'impact que ça peut avoir sur
la capacité Québec à maintenir,
à garder ces entreprises ici?
Parce qu'on vit pas
en vase clos.
- Absolument.
On est d'accord avec vous
là-dessus. Mais il faut aussi
que la grande entreprise
fasse sa juste part.
Puisqu'elle bénéficie
des travailleurs, travailleuses
formés par notre système
d'éducation, d'un système de
sécurité publique, d'un système
de santé. Alors, il faut
qu'elles fassent leur part.
Mais je rappellerais à
la population que la grande
entreprise, au début du 20e...
du 21e siècle, pardon, était
imposée à 30 %. Nous, on suggère
de passer de 11,7 à 14,5.
On n'est pas dans quelque chose
d'impossible. Et au contraire,
je pense que, pour améliorer
tout ça, on va leur offrir du
monde qui va être mieux formé,
des enfants qui vont être plus
en santé pour leurs travailleurs
et travailleuses, plus en santé
au niveau buccodentaire...
- Mais ça fait quand même
une différence, quand même,
3 points de différence.
- Oui... Bien, et c'est sûr...
- Ces entreprises-là peuvent
fermer puis c'est des emplois,
quand même, non?
- Ce que l'entreprise souhaite,
c'est de la prévisibilité.
Alors, nous, on dit que, sur
l'espace de 5 ans, d'un mandat,
on va passer de 11,7 à 14,5.
Ce qu'on dit, c'est : Oui, on a
le courage politique de faire
ça. Et vous savez, prenons,
par exemple, les ressources
naturelles, bien, elles vont
pas déménager, nos ressources
naturelles; elles vont rester
au Québec. Elles sont au Québec,
ces ressources-là. Alors, on
pense que les entreprises aussi.
Ça se peut qu'il y a en qui
partent. Mais entre moi et vous,
nadame Galipeau, on a perdu
Rona, on a perdu Saint-Hubert,
on a perdu plein d'entreprises
et c'étaient pas les mesures...
- Et sans augmenter leur part.
- Exactement.
- On a du mal à savoir vraiment
quel rôle va jouer l'État
sous Québec solidaire. On a du
mal à définir aussi ce parti-là.
Comment vous, vous
le définissez? Parce que
je sais qu'il y a eu toutes
sortes d'étiquettes qui ont été
lancées. Vous aimez pas ça.
Mais vous, comment vous
le définissez, Québec solidaire?
- Bien, pour moi, c'est clair,
ce pourquoi on a fondé ce parti-
là, il y a 12 ans, c'est
parce qu'on trouvait que
les vieux partis faisaient plus
leur travail pour prendre soin
des gens, de tous les gens.
Pas seulement ceux qui sont
en haut de l'échelle ou les plus
pauvres qui sont vraiment en bas
de l'échelle, mais de l'ensemble
de la population à travers
les services publics, à travers
la redistribution de la
richesse. Moi, je pense juste
que Québec solidaire vient dire
au Québec : «On est capables
d'intervenir dans l'économie,
notamment, puisque c'est votre
préoccupation, pour permettre
un développement économique
au service de tout le monde et
non pas seulement, par exemple,
au service des multinationales
qui retirent les ressources
naturelles de notre sol et les
envoient se faire transformer
à l'extérieur.» Alors, nous, on
veut pas tout nationaliser, là.
Ce qu'on veut, c'est,
par exemple, le lithium
qui est actuellement une...
- Ça, ça serait dans
un premier mandat.
- Ça, ça serait dans notre
premier mandat, effectivement...
qui est une ressource
essentielle à la transition
énergétique. Puisque ça compose
les batteries pour stocker
l'électricité qui font déplacer
les voitures, bon, etc.
Alors nous, on dit :
On a, au Québec, du lithium.
Alors, Québec solidaire veut
prendre le contrôle public,
pas la nationalisation.
On veut prendre le contrôle...
- Pas la nationalisation?
- Non. C'est 50 plus 1.
Donc, le contrôle public.
Donc, dire qu'on va avoir un
partenaire économique là-dedans,
privé. Et ensemble, on va
extraire le lithium, on va
le transformer au Québec.
On va construire des batteries.
On va recycler nos batteries
et on va faire faire un cycle
complet. Mais pas en Chine,
ici, au Québec.
- Il y a cette chicane assez
publique entre Québec solidaire
et le Parti québécois.
On sait que vous aviez refusé
la convergence avec le Parti
québécois. Visiblement,
Jean-François Lisée a pas
tellement apprécié.
Et là, il y a Gilles Duceppe
qui en remet aujourd'hui
et qui met en cause vos qualités
de leadership, en fait,
la qualité de votre français.
Il s'en prend assez durement
à vous. Qu'est-ce que
vous répondez?
- Bien, écoutez,
personnellement, être attaquée
de toutes parts, c'est
l'histoire de ma vie.
Mais je trouve ça profondément
irrespectueux pour les gens
qui viennent pas nécessairement
de l'élite. Et je pense que moi,
quand j'ai décidé de faire de la
politique et d'aller au niveau
de la politique du gouvernement
au... au niveau du Québec,
c'est justement le signal
que je voulais envoyer, c'est :
La politique, ce n'est pas
la seule à faire de l'élite.
Ça nous appartient à tout
le peuple. Et moi, je suis
fière d'où je viens.
Et si monsieur... monsieur...
- Duceppe.
- Duceppe... trouve que c'est
pas digne, bien moi, je pense
qu'il faut qu'il s'adresse
aux gens. Parce que moi,
je viens du monde ordinaire.
- Donc, il y a pas
de rapprochement possible, là,
entre souverainistes,
entre progressistes avec
le Parti québécois? Parce que
dans certaines circonscriptions,
vous réalisez bien que ça peut
peut-être laisser passer
un libéral ou un caquiste?
- Euh... oui! Mais c'est ça,
le propre de la politique,
madame Galipeau. On a,
au Québec, une vingtaine
de partis politiques,
dont quatre qui sont
présentement représentés
à l'Assemblée nationale. C'est
ça, le jeu de la politique.
C'est : nous, on a des idées.
On le sait que les autres, aucun
autre parti propose nos idées.
Même l'indépendance est pas
soutenue par M. Lisée de la même
façon. Nous, on propose que ce
soit la souveraineté du peuple
qui soit mise de l'avant.
Même ça, il le soutient pas.
Alors, pourquoi on s'allierait
à quelqu'un comme ça qui,
au gré du vent... pardon,
réenligne son tir pour avoir
des votes? Donc, nous, on est
constants. Depuis 12 ans,
c'est la même marche.
- Donc, pas de rapprochement,
alors, possible?
- Bien, sur des dossiers,
ça a toujours été et ça
le sera encore, sur des choses
spécifiques. Le jour où on va
mettre en marche le processus
de l'indépendance Québec,
je suis certaine qu'on va
le faire ensemble. Mais ceci,
je pense que M. Lisée doit
s'en mordre les doigts.
Le Parti québécois doit
Le mode de scrutin piège
s'en mordre les doigts.
les électeurs et voici
Le mode de scrutin piège
un autre des pièges dans
les électeurs et voici
lesquels ils sont pris.
un autre des pièges dans
- D'ailleurs, si vous avez
lesquels ils sont pris.
éventuellement la balance du
- D'ailleurs, si vous avez
pouvoir, dans ces élections,
éventuellement la balance du
il reste quatre jours
pouvoir, dans ces élections,
maintenant, ça serait
il reste quatre jours
une de vos priorités, ça, le...
maintenant, ça serait
Ça serait une de vos demandes,
une de vos priorités, ça, le...
en tout cas?
Ça serait une de vos demandes,
- Bien, c'est clair, je veux
en tout cas?
dire. Et M. Legault et M. Lisée
- Bien, c'est clair, je veux
se sont engagés à faire
dire. Et M. Legault et M. Lisée
la réforme du mode de scrutin
se sont engagés à faire
dans la première année de leur
la réforme du mode de scrutin
gouvernement, s'ils prenaient
dans la première année de leur
le pouvoir. Nous, c'est dans
gouvernement, s'ils prenaient
notre programme depuis toujours.
le pouvoir. Nous, c'est dans
Parce qu'on croit
notre programme depuis toujours.
en la démocratie. C'est ça,
Parce qu'on croit
la démocratie. C'est que
en la démocratie. C'est ça,
chaque vote compte. Alors,
la démocratie. C'est que
c'est clair que, pour nous,
chaque vote compte. Alors,
c'est un incontournable.
c'est clair que, pour nous,
Et on espère qu'ils vont
c'est un incontournable.
respecter leur parole.
Et on espère qu'ils vont
- On va souhaiter, madame Massé,
respecter leur parole.
une bonne fin de campagne